[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos como hoy
analizamos la caótica situación que vive
afganistán tras la toma de la capital de
kabul por el grupo talibanes después de
una ofensiva que en menos de dos semanas
se llevó al control del país en paralelo
a la retirada de las tropas de eeuu y de
la otan para ello nos acompañó a
fernando coche analista internacional
experto en riesgo de seguridad y
geopolítica está desde madrid' con
nosotros desde españa fernando los
avances hechos durante los 20 años de
guerra contra el talibán desechos en
tres meses de ofensiva insurgente esto
es señal de una mala estrategia de eeuu
o de una debilidad del ejército afgano
bueno es un doble-doble una cromática
una triple problemática es el fracaso
sistemático de la política internacional
de eeuu por lo menos en los últimos 50
años dado que tanto no olvidemos de la
época de vietnam como ahora en
afganistán han fracasado
sistemáticamente después de muchos años
de conflicto evidentemente también es un
problema de la debilidad del gobierno
afgano que es un sistema muy complejo de
clanes muy complejo de etnias que se
dividen digamos el poder en afganistán y
el tercer problema es que realmente no
ha habido la implicación de crear una
estructura una infraestructura política
una infraestructura social que pudiera
hacer frente o contrarrestar al poder
talibán y a su vez formar un estado en
la media de lo posible más democrático y
más sólido mire el informe de
inteligencia de eeuu decía inicialmente
que se iban a demorar 90 días en llegar
hasta kabul y esto sucedió en una semana
prácticamente los talibanes avanzaron
casi sin oposición en ninguna de las
grandes ciudades
esto significa que cuentan con el apoyo
del pueblo
no en absoluto no significa que cuenta
con el pueblo apoyo al pueblo sino que
al retirarse al decir que se retira la
coalición internacional al empezar a
plantearse ya abandonar las embajadas y
por tanto el miedo de los que ayudaron a
generar el sistema democrático allí en
afganistán que es lo que está provocando
las avalanchas el aeropuerto en las
carreteras para huir de kabul lo antes
posible pues esto significa que la gente
ya se da cuenta de que no hay nadie
contra quien luchar contra los talibanes
por tanto si eeuu o la policía
internacional era quien podía ofrecer
frente a ellos no les de frente para qué
gastar vidas lo que prefiere es huir o
directamente es rendirse a los talibanes
por eso ha sido tan tan rápido eeuu
pensaba una vez más en un fallo de
inteligencia que iba a haber una mayor
resistencia o una mayor dificultad de
avance pero cuando los afganos se ven
abandonados por tercera vez ya en lo que
llevamos de
siglo 20 y 21 pues les han dejado pasar
qué le espera la ciudadanía si se re
impone unas áreas radicales qué pasará
con las mujeres y con la reconfiguración
del territorio
pues esto es para mí muy muy doloroso
tener que decirlo pero es va a ser dolor
sufrimiento y mucho me temo que
afganistán como dicen muchos los
analistas y muchos expertos va a
convertirse un estado fallido en un
estado terrorista un estado que financia
apoyo apoya entrena al terrorismo y un
estado narco porque es donde se va a
crear amapola que desde que sale era la
heroína durante el opio durante
muchísimo tiempo por tanto ahora con la
financiación del terrorismo y la
financiación de las drogas me temo que
el talibán se va a hacer mucho más
fuerte de lo que era incluso ya hace 20
años para las mujeres caos desprecio y
además volver otra vez al siglo 15 con
la opresión que se implica pero esta vez
con la connivencia de los pactos de eeuu
los pactos con rusia los pactos con la
unión europea y por tanto del abandono
sistemático del primer mundo a
afganistán una vez más y para cerrar ya
en un mensaje francamente decepcionante
del presidente afgano es ralph gan y
aseguró que se fue del país para evitar
un baño de sangre qué mensaje le da esto
pues que están perdidos están
absolutamente perdidos y que tienen dos
opciones o salir corriendo del gran stan
en una diáspora lo más rápida posible o
sufrir la represalia de los talibanes
que tienen sus listas negras de gente
colaboracionista o colaboradora de la
alianza internacional o ser el master
igual de los talibanes para preservar su
vida
el mensaje me parece decepcionante y el
mensaje es de abandono absoluto de bajar
los brazos de bajar al apoyo y vamos a
ver lo que ocurre en los próximos meses
y luego curas próximos meses no digo
años meses será lo que afganistán será
una vez más durante décadas gracias
fernando y a nuestros televidentes sigan
en france 24 volvemos más adelante
[Música]